hi everybody I'm Jonathan Trott's and
today I have a particularly tricky
puzzle for you guys to try to solve now
some really high rated players have
really struggled on this one so we're
going to see how long it takes you to
solve this tactical challenge and in
this position it's white to move so go
ahead and pause your video and we'll see
if you can solve this really hard puzzle
okay I hope you weren't tricked into
playing the move then lots of people
have tried to play which is Bishop to c
7 which is a really big temptation in
this position because it looks like
you're going to win material and you are
but here black and move his queen away
to e6 and even though white gets to take
the rook black is still up material he's
up in exchange and upon and he has the
much better chances of winning this
position so in our initial position the
best move is actually Queen to be three
check and blacks going to have some
problems if you can see the checkmate
right away you might notice he has some
ways to block the check the best he can
do is to throw away his Bishop throw
away his Queen and when black steps onto
the H file I hope you see the mate
that's coming here night to g6 checkmate
I hope you enjoyed this video hopefully
it was tricky for a lot of you hopefully
I got to stump a lot of people out there
and if you want to see more videos like
this subscribe to our YouTube channel
thanks for watching